there are three words that explain why I
am here they are Amy Krauss Rosenthal at
the end of Amy's life hyped up on
morphine and home in hospice the New
York Times published an article she
wrote for the modern love column on
March 3rd 2017 it was read worldwide by
over 5 million people the piece was
unbearably sad ironically funny and
brutally honest while it was certainly
about our life together the focus of the
piece was me it was called you may want
to marry my husband and was a creative
play on a personal ad for me
Amy quite literally left a empty space
for me to fill with another love story
Amy was my wife for half my life she was
my partner in raising three wonderful
now grown children
and really she was my girl you know we
had so much in common
we loved the same art the same
documentaries the same music music was a
huge part of our life together and we
shared the same values we were in love
and our love grew stronger up until her
last day Amy was a prolific author in
addition to two groundbreaking memoirs
she published over 30 children's books
posthumously the book she wrote with our
daughter Paris called dear girl reached
the number one position on the New York
Times bestseller list she was a
self-described tiny filmmaker she was 5
feet 1 and her films were not that long
her films exemplified her natural
ability to gather people together she
was also a terrific public speaker
talking with children and adults of all
ages all
over the world now my story of grief is
only unique in the sense of it being
rather public however the grieving
process itself is not my story alone Amy
gave me permission to move forward and
I'm so grateful for that now just a
little over a year into my new life I've
learned a few things I'm here to share
with you part of the process of moving
forward through and with grief but
before I do that I think it would be
important to talk a little bit about the
end of life because it forms how I have
been emotionally since that death is
such a taboo subject right Amy ate her
last meal on january 9th 2017 she
somehow lived an additional two months
without solid food her doctors told us
we could do Hospice at home or in the
hospital he did not tell us that Amy
would shrink to half her body weight but
she would never lay with her husband
again and that walking upstairs to our
bedroom would soon feel like running a
marathon home hospice does have an aura
of being a beautiful environment to die
in how great that you don't have the
sounds of machines beeping and going on
and off all the time no disruptions for
mandatory drug administration home with
your family to die we did our best to
make those weeks as meaningful as we
could
we talked often about death everybody
knows it's gonna happen to them like for
sure but being able to talk openly about
it was liberating we talked about
subjects like parenting I asked Amy how
I could be the best parent possible to
our children in her absence
in those conversations she gave me
confidence by stressing what a great
relationship I had with each one of them
and that I can do it I know there will
be many times where I wish she and I can
make decisions together we were always
so in sync may I be so audacious
to suggest that you have these
conversations now when healthy please
don't wait as part of our hospice
experience we organize groups of
visitors how brave of a me to receive
them even as she began her physical
decline we had a Krause night her
parents and three siblings friends and
family were next each told beautiful
stories of a me and of us a me made an
immense impact on her loyal friends but
home Hospice is not so beautiful for the
surviving family members I want to get a
little personal here and tell you that
to this date I have memories of those
final weeks that haunt me I remember
walking backwards to the bathroom
assisting Amy with each step I felt so
strong not such a big guy but my arms
looked and felt so healthy compared to
Amy's frail body that body failed in our
house on March 13th of last year my wife
died of ovarian cancer in our bed I
carried her lifeless body down our
stairs through our dining room in our
living room to a waiting gurney to have
her body cremated I will never get that
image out of my head if you know someone
who's been through the hospice
experience acknowledge that just say you
heard this guy Jason talk about how
tough it must be to have those memories
and that you're there if they ever want
to talk about it they may not want to
talk but it's nice to connect with
someone living each day with those
lasting images I know this sounds
unbelievable but I've never been asked
that question amy's essay caused me to
experience grief in a public way many of
the readers who reached out to me wrote
beautiful
words of reflection the scope of Amy's
impact was deeper and richer and even us
and her family knew some of the
responses I received help me with the
intense grieving process because of
their humor like this email I received
from a woman reader who read the article
declaring I will marry you when you are
ready provided you permanently stop
drinking no other conditions I promise
to outlive you thank you very much now I
do like a good tequila but that really
is not my issue yet how could I say no
to that proposal
I laughed through the tears when I read
this note from a family friend
I remember Shabbat dinners at your home
and Amy teaching me how to make corn
bread croutons only Amy could find
creativity in croutons on July 27th just
a few months after Amy's death my dad
died of complications related to a
decades-long battle with Parkinson's
disease I had to wonder how much can the
human condition handle what makes us
capable of dealing with this intense
Lawson yet carry on was this a test why
my family and my amazing children
looking for answers I regret to say is a
lifelong mission but the key to my being
able to persevere is Amy's express and
very public edict that I must go on
throughout this year I have done just
that
I have attempted to step out and seek
the joy and the beauty that I know this
life is capable of providing but here's
the reality those family gatherings
attending weddings and events honoring
Amy as loving as they are have all been
very difficult to endure people say I'm
amazing how do you handle yourself that
way during those times they say
you do it with such grace you know guess
what I really am sad a lot of the time I
often feel like I'm kind of a mess and I
know these feelings apply to other
surviving spouses children parents and
other family members in Japanese Zen
there is a term Shoji which translates
as birth death there is no separation
between life and death other than a thin
line that connects the two birth or the
joyous wonderful vital parts of life and
death those things we want to get rid of
are said to be faced equally in this new
life that I find myself in I am doing my
best to embrace this concept as I move
forward with grieving in the early
months following Amy's death though I
was sure that the feeling of despair
would be ever-present that it would be
all-consuming soon I was fortunate to
receive some promising advice many
members of the losing a spouse club
reached out to me one friend in
particular who had also lost her life
partner kept repeating Jason you will
find joy I didn't even know what she was
talking about how was that possible
but because Amy gave me very public
permission to also find happiness
I now have experienced joy from time to
time there it was dancing the night away
at an LCD Soundsystem concert traveling
with my brother and best friend or with
a college buddy on a boy's trip to meet
a group of great guys I never met before
from observing that my deck had son
meeting down on it on a cold day
stepping out in it laying there the
warmth consuming my body the joy comes
from my three stunning children there
was my son Justin texting me a picture
of himself with an older gentleman with
a mass
strong forearm and the caption I just
met Popeye with a huge grin on his face
there was his brother miles walking to
the train for his first day of work
after graduating college he stopped and
looked back at me and asked what am I
forgetting I assured him right away you
are 100 percent ready you got this and
my daughter Paris walking together
through Battersea Park in London the
leaves piled high the Sun glistening in
the early morning on our way to yoga I
would add that beauty is also fair to
discover
I mean beauty of the wabi-sabi variety
but beauty nonetheless
on the one hand when I see something in
this category I want to say Amy did you
see that did you hear that it's too
beautiful for you not to share with me
on the other hand I now experience these
moments in an entirely new way there is
the beauty I found in music like the
moment in the newest Manchester
Orchestra album when the song the aliens
seamlessly transitions into the sunshine
or the haunting beauty of Luke C tal
sings it's killing me whose chorus reads
and it's killing me that you're not here
with me I'm living happily but I'm
feeling guilty there is beauty in the
simple moments that life has to offer a
way of seeing the world that was so much
a part of Amy's DNA like on my morning
commute looking at the Sun reflecting
off of Lake Michigan we're stopping and
truly seeing how the light shines at
different times of the day in the house
we built together even after a Chicago
storm noticing the fresh buildup of snow
throughout the neighborhood or peeking
into my daughter's room as she's
practicing the bass guitar
listen I want to make it clear that I'm
a very fortunate person I have the most
amazing family that loves and supports
me I have the resources for personal
growth during my time of grief but
whether it's a divorce losing a job you
work so hard or having a family member
die suddenly or of a slow moving and
painful death I would like to offer you
what I was given a blank sheet of paper
what will you do with your intentional
empty space with your fresh start
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]